the problem with such a small
fund historically
is that
you david are not going to have a lot of
fees to live off of
even if you got three percent on three
million dollars only 90k a year
so how are you going to survive
in terms of fees what are you thinking
of fee shrugs
that's why it's a good thing that i have
the acquired podcast with ben and uh my
partner in this in kindergarten nat
manning is the ceo of a company called
kettle so he's full-time found perfect
and yeah this is for our deal flow on
the side
love it
this is a great way to start off you
have other revenue sources and as people
know my first fund i just did a 20 carry
and no fees
we're not taking fees it's eight because
we didn't think it's right because we're
both full-time on other things and okay
because what are we going to do
anyway but you should any legal fees or
accounting or something you can put
against it but you're not taking
management fees and that's why i did
that on my first one as well and that
fund had calm
and uh robin hood in it so haven't heard
congratulations by the way
i i think that fund
yeah it's it'll be in a way
except i don't plan on selling robinhood
shares for a decade personally i will
distribute the shares at some point to
our lps when our lock ups up but
i i don't see a case for me wanting to
sell those shares
when the company's only worth 30 billion
it's got 22 million
active users i don't know how you you
all feel about it so you're not like
feeling take the win lock it in
heck no
think about the last double up the last
two double ups in this game
are so material oh
we preached about this unacquired all
the freaking time this is the mistake
the sequoia learned with their apple
investment they sold their apple
investment for six million dollars total
they owned like 20 of the company makes
no sense you want to ride your winners
as we've been saying on the all-in
podcast a bunch and it's time in market
not timing the market
i i could see i know this sounds crazy
to folks i could see
some of this cohort that came out in the
last
group of decacorns
coinbase
because i do think crypto is going to be
around for a while i could see coinbase
airbnb uber doordash
i could have seen slack and certainly
robin hood
i could see all of those having a 10 to
20 x in them yeah
there's a great this is perfect for the
the theme the the meat of the episode in
a little bit that we'll get into yeah it
is actually if you were to look at that
cohort
hey
i'm starting to start up what do you
think i really like the pod that it's a
shame david hasn't had uh firepower
until now to take advantage of it so i
love the strategy i also love i'm a
proud investor uh myself
and i asked
maybe a little sub that i'm early on the
journey but i guess
to make what can you promise me what's
what what kind of reporting are you
gonna send me and what's my portfolio
instruction gonna look like and
portfolio construction gonna look like
and
what stage you playing at and he just
laughed at me and he was like yeah i
mean
i'll let you know when there's returns
so perfect i like the light lift that
he's got going on i like that as well
now to be an lp in a fund
i do think there's two things putting
aside returns we we're going to be
pretty sure dave is going to get good
returns he's got great deal flow he's
established in the industry anybody
who's a startup that wants to get 25 50k
would be you know wise to take his money
i think that's a no-brainer
or even 100 but you're going to add a
lot to it
but i do think thinking about when
you're an lp in a fund i'm in 20 funds
or so and i can't be in any more but i
am thinking about being in this one
and the way i would think about it is
are you going to let us know about the
deals in real time as you do them in one
of these micro funds
david yeah so the plan is yes we're
still just getting up and running i've
been thinking about setting up a private
channel in the acquired slack
for
and just putting all kindergarten folks
in their lp's our founders and if you do
it i'm do if you're i'm in for that i'll
put in 25 if you do that great 25k to
get access to the slack channel well i
already have access to selection because
jason burr of acquired fm but i'm
thinking if you do a deal and you're
putting 25 in maybe that's just you know
good signal for me for a downstream
syndicate investment great downstream or
current right it could be current yeah
sure but you know
i'm going to assume some of those rounds
might be closing up quickly and maybe i
don't get into them but
you know so that's what i was thinking
is yeah things are going on we post
about it in the cycle like okay and then
with the founders are in there and the
rlps are
probably the largest group of lps is is
gp's other venture firms and then we've
got other great folks in there that was
mark andreessen's plan he was in our
first fund he was in my first fund and
he came out of nowhere and so i heard
you're raising a fund i was like would
you hear that from me say hi i'm marc
andreessen and he's i'll put 50k in
and then uh
i kicked him out of the second fund or
didn't invite him back because i invited
him on the podcast and he said yeah no
i'm not going to make it and then his pr
people were like oh you can have all
these other people in the podcast and i
was like no
mark should come do a keynote at the
event and then mark was like do i have
to be on your podcast
and come to your events and do keynotes
in order to be in business with you can
i just run back one word yes
well i was just like you know what
you're being a jerk for no reason and
you're on everybody else's podcast
you're on panda which is trashing you
constantly if you're on panda.com or
whatever come on my podcast like it's
you know
a question for you by the way where all
the act that's where all the acrimony
comes from with me and mark
what is the origin
of
the twist name this week in startups
so i was on this week in tech with leo
laporte yep because that's what i was
wondering
i i asked him hey can i use the name to
do this week in stardust because i was
only able to be on it was very hard to
get a slot on this weekend tech and i
would be on one out of every four or
five episodes
and i was trying to be on more because
he's trying to pick my profile but it
was just like kevin rose was on and all
these famous people were on at the time
and i was like hey i want to talk about
startups more because it was this week
intact it was more about the new iphone
and whatever and he was like yeah go for
it and then i started doing other this
weekends and
that kind of pissed him off a little bit
but we worked it out we hashed it out
nice
because i was wondering ben and i were
actually talking about this
why
at this point
shouldn't you just call this jason
calacana show 100 yeah at some point but
i i kind of like my legacy of this week
in startups but yeah i'm doing it four
days a week five days a week so it's a
jason gallagher show yeah i'll take that
under advisement and it's where i go to
get my
direct drip of jason because what i'm
listening to all in your boys are
trashing you a little bit they're taking
the mic they're running with it they
talk too long and then you try and talk
and someone's oh pass the ball why can't
you learn to pass the ball so it's nice
to have the straight stuff
thank you for that it's it's actually
made it easier now that i'm doing four
or five days a week on this show
when i'm doing an interview with
somebody i don't need to interject as
much because people got their fill of
jason from when i do the news up front
and then i do the interview
on most episodes and then then on all in
i'm just like you know what i'm just the
point guard i don't need to shoot i'm
just a pass first point guard and if i
get some reps in fine you're gonna get
enough of me from that
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business blog or publish
content promote your business announce
upcoming events or special projects and
sell products and services of all kinds
and more they also have powerful
ecommerce functionality and everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box so no matter what you're using an
ipad
a surface a iphone an android phone it
doesn't matter all these beautiful
templates just work and of course it's
got built-in seo free and secure hosting
and 24 7 award-winning customer support
we did remote demo day in 2020 we were
suffering through the pandemic we were
confused how are these startups going to
get funded i said throw up a squarespace
site it's a project maybe it turns into
a business and boy did it ever we have
now funded over
a dozen companies over 14 million
dollars in funding and this all from
setting up a simple squarespace website
and tweeting it so go to squarespace.com
twist for a free trial squarespace.com
twist for a free trial when you're ready
to launch use the offer code twist and
save ten percent off your first purchase
of a website or domain and
congratulations for the team uh going
public by direct listing on may 19th
what an amazing journey it's been
congratulations again okay let's get
back to this amazing episode